Yeah.
I covered
my place because they're taking
and all that stuff.
I mean,
this is what we've come
to in America, huh?
These guys call themselves patriots.
Really?
The effects of election
conspiracy theories
already on full display
here in the swing state of Arizona
Armed men stalking vote drop box
prompting voters to hide their i
and even cover their license pla
as they go to vote for guy
standing over there.
He's got his face covered.
He's got and he's armed.
What's that tell you?
They don't want you to vote
they don't want you to vote.
Ballot drop
boxes are a target of conspiracy
theorists
who falsely believe that they we
to steal the 2020 election.
It's called 2000 mules.
Central to all of this is the mo
2000 Mules.
It was released in May,
and Trump even hosted
a screening of it at Mar a Lago.
The movie
falsely claims that so-called mu
are casting
hundreds or thousands of votes
at drop boxes.
We're actually seeing mules
be intimidated
for, you know, from doing their
The organizer behind
many of the drop
box watchers
said she was inspired by the mov
to take action.
We believe that there was someth
stolen in 2020
and just because you don't. We d
but the kind of people
are group are seeing are not mul
They are real voters who are now
I could never come down here alo
And, you know, I couldn't do it
It's scary.
It's just flat out insane.
It's voter intimidation.
The movie has been roundly debun
by cyber experts and election of
This is not a technical report
that would hold any water.
This is not research
And indeed,
when we see what governments
who have been provided with this
data have said,
it's pretty clear
that they're deeply unimpressed
with this as well.
Thank you, Mr. President.
Even former Attorney General Bil
who was appointed by Trump,
told this to the January six com
The election was not stolen by f
and I
haven't seen
anything since the election
that changes my mind on that,
including the 2000 Mules movie
Nevertheless, the lies persist.
If you talk to people
who don't believe
that the election was fair
and 20, 29 times
out of ten,
one of the first things
they're going to bring up is 200
You've seen it? I sure have.
What do you think?
I think very accurate.
Very accurate.
And I think
they're going to try it again.
We met Enola Gay Pigeons
and her son
Roger, outside an event for Carr
the Republican election denier
running for governor of Arizona.
They swear by the movie.
How many times have you seen mor
I've watched it three times.
Republican chair
of the Maricopa County Board
of Supervisors
warns the lies in the movie
are a threat to democracy.
They've dehumanized folks
with this term fuel.
These are people
who are exercising their
right to vote in this democracy.
This dehumanization
that's going on
in our political discourse
right now
is very dangerous because it doe
the use of violence.
People who want to watch 2000 mu
have to pay up to 20 or $30 a pr
many are willing to pay.
I bought actually the 2000 mules
to hand out to friends
that are nonbelievers,
and they come back
and they go, Oh, my God,
I have many copies that you buy.
All total. I bought 12 copies.
But not all Republicans
want to buy into the lies.
And I'm a Republican,
but I'm an American first.
I mean, it's funny.
I mean, I voted a lot of times.
I'm in my sixties
and this is the first time that
elections ever been stolen, righ
I mean, come on
now.
A federal judge ruling overnight
that armed men
like you see in that piece
there, they need to stay
at least 250 feet away from thes
drop boxes.
Arizona is, of course,
an open carry state,
but it's not really a good look
what is supposed to be
a healthy democracy
if you have guys with guns
at the ballot box.
So quickly here, just to be clea
these are Democrats and Republic
They're equally disturbed by thi
What they absolutely.
The last gentleman we spoke to,
they're a lifelong Republican
and he thinks that this
is all really a disgrace.